thank you very much and thank you all
for coming out tonight I know people
have busy schedules and it's hard to
time find time for things like this but
I appreciate your taking the time to
come out and listen to me and learn a
little bit about Justice Clarence Thomas
I'd also like to welcome our c-span
audience welcome to Atlanta and welcome
to the Morgan Mitchell house the book is
judging Thomas the life and times of
Clarence Thomas the publishers William
Morrow an imprint of HarperCollins the
website is judging Thomas calm and there
is an excerpt available online at a JC
com that ran in the August 15th edition
of the Atlanta journal-constitution
my name is Ken Fosca I'm a reporter with
the Atlanta journal-constitution
and I am the author of judging Thomas
one of the most interesting things to me
about doing this book about Justice
Clarence Thomas was that I got to spend
a lot of time at the United States
Supreme Court which unfortunately is a
place that most Americans don't get a
chance to see particularly from the
inside and when I was up there I was
always trying to figure out what it
reminded me of sometimes I thought it
was like a big bank other times I
thought it was like a rare book library
I concluded that actually getting in to
see the justices is a little bit like
scaling the walls of the Emerald City
and getting to meet the man behind the
curtain the last time that I saw justice
Thomas who was up in his chambers in
Washington in July of 2003 just about a
year ago and to give you a picture of
what that's like his chamber is rather
small by the sort of lavish standards of
executive office suites today it is very
much like a library there are
bookshelves on on two walls
there is a fireplace on one wall and
Justice Thomas when he is interviewing
or greeting visitors sits in a big
director's chair in the middle of the
room and he sort of wheels around and
grabs the gloss off his desk or off the
bookshelf and like most people he has
chosen to decorate his office with
things that are particularly meaningful
to him behind his desk there is a
portrait of Frederick Douglass over the
fireplace there is one of Booker T
Washington and over the sofa there is a
black and white photograph that was
taken by Walker Evans in the 1930s and
it shows the negro quarter of Savannah
of that time period and the reason that
Justice Thomas has that photograph is
because it reminds him of the corner and
the tenement building that he lived in
with his mother when he was six years
old in the mid 1950s and his mother was
working as a maid in Savannah and he was
home alone or wandering the streets or
sometimes in school and I had been told
by friends of justice Thomas's that his
Supreme Court confirmation in 1991 was
not the most difficult challenge that he
had ever faced in his life and I asked
him whether that was true and he said
yes and I said well what was the most
difficult and without thinking he jerked
his head up and he said that and he
pointed to the photograph on the wall
and I said what do you mean by that and
he said that was real that's what I'm
trying to work through I tell that story
because one of the things that's
happened that has happened in our
political life today is that our public
officials have become caricatures of
themselves almost like postcards and the
reality is that they are mostly very
complicated
and complex human beings and one of the
things that I wanted to do in judging
Thomas was to keep my focus on the man
especially Clarence Thomas because
Clarence Thomas has become this sort of
political football in our society who
gets punted around between liberals and
conservatives to advance one agenda or
another and I was really interested in
the guy I wanted to know what made him
tick what he liked and what he didn't
like how he became the man he is today
Clarence Thomas I think is a puzzle to
most Americans and he was to me he is
black and conservative at a time when
most black Americans of his generation
tended to be more liberal and democratic
he benefited from affirmative action but
he opposes it now he is a very very
private man particularly since his
confirmation sort of erected this very
stone wall around himself but this is
also a man that breaks down in tears
while giving public speeches and I
actually saw that happen once and as
everybody knows he doesn't ask very many
questions from the Supreme Court bench
when people who know him and as I
learned through my reporting this is a
man who loves to talk and loves to
debate and loves to engage people so I
was I wanted to know about that guy and
see if I could solve some of these
riddles and I wanted to do so without
passing judgment on his politics or his
beliefs so let me just touch on a few
things now about Clarence Thomas that I
think will help you understand him and
the first thing you need to know about
Clarence Thomas is that he was raised by
a man by the name of Myers Anderson his
grandfather Clarence Thomas his parents
divorced when he was quite young he
lived with
mother for a period of time and then he
went to live with my errs Anderson and
there's no question that Meyers Anderson
sort of played the biggest role in
shaping him into the man he is today and
I'm gonna read now just a short passage
from the book that picks up at the time
when Clarence Thomas is leaving his
mother's care and going to live with his
grandfather in 1955 in the summer of
1955 Clarence Thomas left his mother's
to the tenement in Savannah clutching a
brown paper shopping bag stuffed with
everything he owned the seven-year-old
walked with his mother and younger
brother Myers who carried his own paper
bag
the abrupt departure came with no
warning and little explanation from his
mother they were going to live with
their grandparents she told them she
would see them when she could she said
having seen his grandfather only once in
his life Clarence knew almost nothing
about the man who was suddenly to be his
guardian he regarded Myers Anderson is
some kind of God a rich man who lived in
a big house and owned both a car and a
truck he was utterly terrified even
before he crossed the threshold at all
man Anderson stood ramrod straight and
walked stiffly years of chopping
firewood his first business had chiseled
his big hands into callous knobs one of
the few photos of him taken much later
in his life shows a lean man dressed in
a white t-shirt Anderson's dark black
skin creased and weather-beaten almost
blends into the mahogany mantelpiece
behind him there's a trace of a scowl
across his face his eyes burned
defiantly at the camera and the muscles
in his body looked tense barely
suppressing the obvious resistance he
felt over being photographed Anderson
delivered heating oil to black customers
in green Ford truck painted letters on
the side advertised his business
Anderson fuel oil company the Anderson's
two-bedroom house built just before
Clarence and Myers arrived surrounded
the boys with luxuries they had never
known a secured roof over their head
an indoor toilet a bedroom of their own
Anderson bought them clothes in decent
shoes his wife Christine the boy's
grandmother made sure they had plenty to
eat
but the comforts came at a price under
Anderson's roof the boys lived by his
strict rules he allowed them no break-in
period and accepted no excuses he
immediately taught his grandsons to tell
time by his clock each morning he walked
before the Sun rose Foday he called it
and he worked from Sun to Sun he put his
grandsons on the same schedule rousing
them before sunrise every day even
during the summer the morning ritual
became so ingrained that Clarence often
sensed his grandfather's presence in the
pre-dawn darkness before he heard his
deep voice get up boy Anderson Bart
y'all think y'all are rich Clarence
Thomas cannot remember a single morning
of his childhood that he was not up to
see daybreak my other favorite story
about Myers Anderson is that the green
Ford trucks that he bought came
installed with heaters Anderson took
them out a heater was a luxury that
would make a working man lazy he
believed there's no question that the
discipline and the work ethic that
Clarence Thomas learned from Myers
Anderson is a big part of the reason
that he was successful in life but the
other point here is that this was a
childhood that was very isolated
Anderson used to say that if you weren't
working you were trifling and he didn't
allow Clarence or his brother to play
after school on the week or on the
weekends when there was work to be done
when you talked to Thomas's friends from
that time period
they remember him in two places sitting
next to his grandfather in his
grandfather's oil truck or in the
library reading Clarence Thomas was a
voracious reader from a very very young
age
and books were one of his few escapes I
point this out because Thomas is
something of a loner and this becomes
significant in terms of what happens
later in his life when he decides that
he is conservative and is going to be a
black member of the Republican Party
being a minority is familiar to him and
not that big a deal
Justice Thomas gave a speech in 2000
where he said I'm very comfortable being
alone in my views he is
the other thing you need to know about
Clarence Thomas is that he was raised in
the Catholic Church and he attended
Catholic parochial schools this was a
very very different experience than most
children of his generation fewer than 5%
of savannahs Catholic families black
Catholic are black families identified
themselves as Catholics and the Catholic
Church with its different rituals and
traditions reinforce the notion with
Clarence Thomas that it was okay to be
different and to hold contrary views
more importantly the Catholic Church
really saved Clarence Thomas the
parochial schools that the church ran in
Savannah offered the best education
possible for a black child growing up in
under segregation in the deep south at
that time and I'm going to read again a
little bit to give you a a taste of what
that experience was like for Clarence
Thomas the school that he attended
beginning in the second grade was called
st. Benedict's st. Benedict's a
three-story brick fortress about eight
blocks from Henderson's house
represented the outer edge of Clarence
Thomas's tiny universe in Savannah nuns
from the order of st. Francis and
priests from the Society of African
missions staff st. benedict's in
savannas to other Catholic elementary
schools dressed in the dark wool habits
of their order the nuns were an
intimidating force the first lesson they
taught was how to address them yes
sister no sister please sister thank you
sister they demanded perfect behavior
from their students Charles Bell a
classmate of Thomas's brother Myers can
still visualize the banner over the
blackboard in one of the classrooms at
st. Benedict's if you want to kill time
you work it to death
the sisters proud their classrooms in
the school halls with rulers ready to
wrap the knuckles of any misbehaving
student you did not have the freedom to
do what you wanted to do sin Pamela
Jones you had to control yourself that
first year the nuns unyielding
discipline almost overwhelmed Clarence
living in pinpoint and then with his
mother he had been mostly unsupervised
accustomed to roaming the streets on his
own even when he was supposed to be in
school his first year at st. Benedict's
he ran straight C's except for a B and
Christian doctrine Anderson's towering
expectations also pressed on him daily
as much as he believed in the importance
of manual skills Anderson was determined
that his grandsons not repeat his life
of hard labor he often told Larenz that
he wanted him to study hard so he could
land quote a coat and tie job knowledge
was the equalizing force in a society
that Anderson's generation knew was far
from equal Anderson sometimes put a
finger to his head and said that once an
idea got in here
no one could remove it knowledge was the
one freedom white people couldn't take
away Anderson expected homework to be
completed before bedtime and he
tolerated no excuses for staying home
from school he didn't hesitate to remind
them with a twenty dollar tuition he was
paying to send--
each of them there he told the boys that
if they died he would continue to take
them school for three days just to be
sure they weren't faking
Anderson made good on the threat after
missing the first two days of second
grade Clarence was never absent or tardy
the seven years he attended st.
benedict's the last point that I'll make
about Clarence Thomas the man is that he
is by nature a contrarian he is always
the guy that's going to go left when
everyone else is going right or I should
say right when everyone else is going
left the discipline that he got from
Myers Anderson and from the church was
very important to him
but there is a part of him that rebelled
and rebelled against being told what to
do
Clarence Thomas hates being told what to
do or how to think or how to act and I
think that's a big reason that he is a
libertarian which if you want to be
accurate about his political orientation
is what he is he doesn't like being told
what to do and he doesn't think the
government should tell people what to do
either
I'm going to go back in time a little
bit and ask you to visualize a little
bit with me here
the year is 1968 the Vietnam War is
raging college students across America
are protesting cities are experienced
something experiencing some of their
worst racial turbulence of the last few
years a young 20 year old black student
from Savannah arrives at the College of
the Holy Cross with a suitcase and a
poster of Malcolm X tucked under his arm
he's dressed in green army fatigues
black combat boots he's got a black
beret on his head with a black power
patch over a very large afro this
student immediately starts organizing
the Black Student Union on campus he
goes down to Washington to protest the
war at the Pentagon he protests in
Worcester and Boston in 1969 he helps
orchestrate a walkout of all the black
students at Holy Cross College to
protest discrimination they're an act
that he calls a quote complete
liberation from the slavery that whites
persist on foisting upon the black man
I'm telling you this story of course
because this is Clarence Thomas Thomas
was a radical in college and very much a
part of the Black Power movement that
was popular on college campuses at that
time period and I had heard stories
about this when I started my reporting
and I was very interested in learning
more about that student and finding out
where he went where did the guy with the
green army fatigues and the black
boots go Thomas's answer to that
question is that he grew up but of
course it's a little bit more
complicated than that it was a an
evolution a period of years but there
were some turning points and one turning
point occurred in 1970 well Clarence
Thomas was at Holy Cross and he was in
Boston protesting the incarceration of
Bobby Seale and other political
prisoners who were scheduled to go on
trial in New Haven later that year and
in this sort of din of angry voices and
shouting and everything he heard a voice
inside his head that said what are you
doing here
why are you here and not in the library
why are you here and not doing something
for yourself and achieving and getting
ahead why are you here and not doing the
one thing that no one in your family has
ever done in 200 years in the United
States which was to get a college degree
and I think that this really was a very
significant moment for Clarence Thomas
and you can see the the two sides of him
in conflict with one another one the
angry man who wants to tear down the
establishment the other the the
disciplined focused mover achiever who
was taught over and over again to
respect authority can play by the rules
and I think for Thomas it came down to a
decision of whether he was going to tear
down the establishment or whether he was
going to be the establishment and of
course we all know which way he went now
you know some people are able to
harmonize parts of themselves that way
Clarence Thomas is not one of those
those people and he's one thing or
another and that was the choice that he
made at that time
in 1974 Clarence Thomas graduated from
Yale Law School with a law degree a
degree from one of the best if not the
best law schools in the country
and he could not get a job he wanted to
be a tax lawyer and a corporate lawyer
most of the law firms that he talked to
wanted to talk to him about civil rights
law and this was a very very frustrating
point in his life he was married he had
a young son he had been sort of living
hand-to-mouth
putting himself through college for the
last seven years he wanted to make some
money he wanted to work in one of these
big silk stocking
law firms rightly or wrongly he blamed
his inability to land a job on
affirmative action he thought that these
white law firms looked at his diploma
differently than they did a white
student and assumed that the only reason
that he had gotten into Yale was because
of affirmative action and that they had
given him some breaks and that they
discounted the hard work and the effort
that he put into it and I'm gonna read a
comment in the book from a friend of his
a very good friend of his who was very
in close touch with Clarence Thomas
during that time period Clarence and I
talked many times about the damage that
affirmative action was doing to our
reputation said his friend Robert de
chelly the things that he and I worked
so hard for had been trashed because of
the perception in the largest larger
society and even among too many black
folks that whatever we have we have
because somebody gave us some break last
Supreme Court term the court upheld the
affirmative action program at the
University of Michigan Law School and
Clarence Thomas wrote a very lengthy and
very passionate dissent and for me the
most interesting lines from that dissent
are these when blacks take positions in
the highest places of government
industry or academia it is an open
question today whether their skin color
played a part in their advancement the
question itself is a stigma because
either affirmative action did play a
role in which case the person may be
deemed quote otherwise unqualified or it
did not
in which case asking the question itself
unfairly marks those blacks who would
succeed without it Clarence Thomas is
talking about himself here did he get to
the Supreme Court because of affirmative
action or did he get there through his
own hard work and effort he'll never
know the answer to that hit that
question and that's his problem with it
let me make a few remarks about justice
Thomas's confirmation which is the
episode that most people probably most
identify him with the first thing I'll
say is that there was an awful lot going
on behind the scenes here that the
American public really didn't get a
chance to see for most Americans
Clarence Thomas's confirmation was about
Anita Hill that was not what it was
about for the members of the Senate and
the interest groups that were either
opposing or supporting his nomination
Anita Hill and her allegations were
another act maybe the final act in a
much larger battle that had been taking
place over Clarence Thomas's nomination
and the future of the federal judiciary
Ronald Reagan came in to office in 1980
and he thought that the courts were too
liberal and he wanted to appoint more
conservatives to the bench
liberals saw this they were alarmed by
this and organized to block these
appointments and the first real major
battle that was fought here was in 1987
with Robert Bork's confirming a
nomination liberal groups waged a very
successful very aggressive grassroots
effort to defeat work Clarence Thomas
came along four years later and it was
largely the same players and the same
actors the irony is that most
conservatives outside of Washington had
never heard of Clarence Thomas but when
they heard liberals saying that they
were going to work Thomas they came out
of the woodwork and came to his defense
as one conservative who was very
involved in that battle told me it was
payback time
opposition to Thomas's nomination came
primarily from two sources from civil
rights organizations and women's groups
of these women's groups were by far the
most energized and organized in 1990 and
91 the Supreme Court had lost two of its
strongest abortion rights justices and
William Brennan and Thurgood Marshall
and it was taken as an article of faith
that Clarence Thomas if confirmed would
be the fifth and deciding vote to
overturn Roe Anita Hill and her
allegations became another tool to try
to block the nomination Anita Hill did
not want to go public with her
allegations she was pushed by liberal
interest groups and by Democratic
members of the Senate Judiciary
Committee and other committees and
ultimately she was outed when her
statement to the committee was leaked to
Nina Totenberg at National Public Radio
some details that didn't get a lot of
play in the hearing Clarence Thomas and
Anita Hill had a personal relationship
before they had a professional one in
1981 in early 1981 Clarence Thomas moved
out of the house had separated from his
first wife and went to live with his
best friend from college Gill Hardy and
was living on Gill Hardy's sofa Anita
Hill lived three floors up she was also
a very very close friend of Gil's heart
Gill Hardy's and had come to Washington
had been recruited to Washington by Gil
Hardy to work at his law firm after she
had graduated from Yale Law School in
1980 Clarence Thomas Anita held net in
Gil Hardy's living room they were a part
of a small network of black attorneys
who had gone to Yale and other
top-flight law firms after that Clarence
Thomas was got an appointment in the
Reagan administration and some months
after that he offered a job to Anita
Hill to work with him there people
always want to know what my take is on
what happened there and I'm happy to
talk about that I think maybe I'll leave
it to the QA whatever the truth there is
no minimizing the impact that these
hearings had on American society sexual
harassment had been in the closet in
this country and it came out and it was
given a national spotlight that had
never had before thousands and thousands
of businesses across this country wrote
guidelines on sexual harassment ripped
up the ones they had conducted training
for employees I I think that really you
could say that there was a sort of a
fundamental shift in workplace relations
that took place in this country as a
result of these hearings on the flip
side this episode personalized politics
I think in a way that hadn't happened
before in Washington and contributed to
the very very partisan poison
environment that we see in Washington a
particularly as it relates to confirming
judges to do the judiciary and the
difficulty there everybody who was
involved in these hearings Democrats and
Republicans alike alike were very bitter
very bruised and very angry about how
this unfolded Anita Hill took serious
damage to her reputation and felt very
very abused by this process Clarence
Thomas was traumatized and a broken man
okay just talk for a few minutes about
Clarence Thomas today thirteen years
after his confirmation um in his
personal life Justice Thomas lives in
Virginia with his second wife in 1997
they adopted a grandnephew of justice
Thomas's from Savannah and justice
Thomas's life revolves very much around
that young boy he leaves the court in
the middle of the afternoon to go pick
him up from the bus stop so you can sort
of visualize the scene of the
silver-haired Supreme Court justice
standing at the bus stop with soccer
moms and sport utility vehicles and he
is very involved in the boys schoolwork
and he gives them extra homework and
they're very involved with his sports
and athletics basketball and one of the
most interesting stories that I I
learned about justice Thomas's that in
1991 he bought a camping bus and we're
not talking about your sort of
garden-variety pop-up trailer this is
one of these big greyhound like buses
that you know rock stars drive around
the country in and Clarence and his wife
and the adopted grand nephew you know go
out in the summertime they take trips
around the country they over night in RV
campsites there have been several
instances where they've been around the
campfire and the people that they're
eating hot dogs with don't seem to
recognize the Supreme Court justice that
they are with or don't seem to seem to
care and
first Thomas really likes that he likes
the anonymity of that and getting away
and sort of being able to be a regular
person in contrast to the sort of dour
and very severe presence that he has on
the Supreme Court Clarence Thomas is
very very well-liked at the Supreme
Court among his other colleagues and
other people in the building he is on a
first-name basis with literally
everybody in the building
he plays hoops with the the call the the
security guards in the gym he lifts
weights he keeps his clerks entertained
with this endless repertoire of bad puns
and one of the his closest colleagues is
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg who was
obviously a different end of the
spectrum ideologically from Justice
Thomas but described him as a most
congenial colleague and talked about how
he's always coming by with a bag of
Georgia Vidalia onions for her husband
who's something of a chef in fact one of
the circuit court judge from New York
told me an interesting story which is
actually not in the book
that among the clerk's who who want a
clerk at the Supreme Court from other
courts Justice Thomas has now considered
the most desirable justice to clerk for
because he takes such an interest in
their personal and professional lives
and gives them work to do
in terms of his jurisprudence Clarence
Thomas is now regarded as the most
conservative justice on the court and he
has achieved what I would describe sort
of Rockstar status among conservatives
and Republicans around this
around the country I think that a lot of
liberals and Democrats and even some in
the media don't fully appreciate how
much Clarence Thomas is respected and
admired and revered so much so that many
want to see him the next Chief Justice
of the United States Supreme Court and
he has already been interviewed for that
job obviously there are a lot of
variables in that and but it is a
possibility that if President Bush is
reelected and the Chief Justice were to
step down that Clarence Thomas would be
the nominee to succeed him
which brings me to my last point about
Clarence Thomas people have always
underestimated this man to give you a
little context in 1991 when he was
confirmed he it was predicted that he
was going to be a Supreme Court footnote
that he was damaged goods tainted by
scandal today this is a man who is a
contender for Chief Justice Clarence
Thomas is a very resilient and
determined man and I'll leave you with
one one anecdote from the book of the
book which comes in 1984 when Ronald
Reagan was elected to his second term
and ironically Clarence Thomas was
almost out of a job there were some
people in at the White House that did
not think that Clarence Thomas was doing
enough to defend the administration from
civil rights critics and Thomas was very
concerned about being used by the
administration he wanted the EEOC to be
independent and he wasn't doing what
they were asking him to do
the Reagan administration never
consulted him on major policy issues
when there were events at the White
House he was given a table at the back
of the room and I'll pick up now from
the end of chapter that's called the
dungeon
Thomas felt the disrespect acutely EEOC
is the place where they send you when
they really just want to give you a job
but they don't expect that much from you
he told Armstrong Williams and ade think
of anybody who has ever left the EEOC
who was revered and accomplished and
sought after nobody but Thomas repeated
something else to Williams you and I are
gonna change that he said we are gonna
become its greatest alumni will show
them will show them patience Thomas told
Williams was an honest man's revenge so
that that's my my talk I'm happy to take
questions now if you are going to ask
questions please come to the microphone
to do it and I am at your disposal
the unfortunately you do have to go to
the mic why do you say Justice Thomas is
a broken man
why was just as Thomas a broken man
well this that whole confirmation for
him was a humiliating absolutely
humiliating experience you know Thomas I
mean you know where he came from he
really he came from pinpoint Georgia he
had you know he had no family no wealth
nothing of any material possessions what
he did have and what he was very proud
of was his name and he felt like he lost
his name during that and and that was a
very very difficult thing for him to
overcome thank you very much
libertarianism is a fairly small group
talk about a very small minority and as
a libertarian I'm kind of interested in
what his what was the seminal event or
the genesis of that that he was he
influenced by Iran or from that school
of libertarianism or was it something
more from the say from the founding
fathers the question is where where did
the libertarian influences come from and
Rand was a huge huge influence on
Clarence Thomas he read all of her books
and in fact to this day he asks his
Supreme Court clerks when they come to
work for him the first time to watch The
Fountainhead which was the movie that
was made in the 1940s out of the book by
the same title and there's a
a part of the book where I actually
describe Clarence Thomas very as very
much like the central character in that
movie who's this
frustrated architect who chooses to
dynamite his own work rather than see it
changed by somebody else he said getting
to the justice was like scaling a wall
how hard was it to get to him did you
gain his trust and how open was he to
your questions and to the book it was a
very long and slow process with Justice
Thomas I wrote him a letter the very
very first time that I tried to
interview him this is when I was
researching the articles that ran in
2001 the profile that I was working on
and I had included in the letter the
fact that I had gone to Yale as an
undergraduate thinking that well he went
to Yale too so maybe that would work in
my favor and then I learned later that
he really doesn't like Yale that much
and that that was probably not the right
thing to say and there was another
instance when I was asking him for an
interview this was after a speech that
he'd give it in Savannah and he turned
around he said why would I want to do
that the media had a chance to tell my
story and blew it you know which point
I'm feeling about this big because there
are people all around but you know I
just I kept I kept trying and when I
when I got the the opportunity to write
the book I wrote along the letter and
said you know I'm gonna now
a book about you and I hope that you'll
you know sit down with me but I'm gonna
do it anyway and he wrote me back and I
would drop him a letter from time to
time I I did a lot of research on his
family and you'll you'll see in the
early chapters of the book there are
there's a lot of information about his
family that Clarence Thomas did not know
and I think that he was very grateful
for that and appreciated that and that
was part of what helped me get over the
wall
I wanted to get your personal opinion on
something that came out in the
confirmations as I understand that the
senators asked Thomas if he had ever
discussed Roe versus Wade with anybody
and he said no I haven't and I also
understand that Roe vs. Wade came about
while Thomas was in law school do you
believe that he never discussed Roe
versus Wade personally yeah I devote
some some aim to that in the book he he
gave that response that same response
before he was asked in public hearing to
the Justice Department people who were
coaching him and telling him what kinds
of questions that he might expect from
the Judiciary Committee and he gave the
same answer then that he did in the
public speech and the the people who
heard that thought that that was crazy
and that no one would believe that but
Clarence Thomas said well that's the
truth and they said well okay then I
guess that's what we have to go with I
don't know I mean I did there's another
fellow quoted in the book who was a
classmate of Thomas's at Yale who's now
on the faculty at Emory and he was
saying that at Yale Roe was not that big
a deal because there were all of these
decisions very much like Roe coming out
and it was just sort of expected from
the Supreme Court at that time now you
know Yale was also mostly men so that
may have had something else to do with
it but that's that's what I have in the
book hey I'm kind of covering the same
territory I didn't know that he
considered himself a libertarian if I
understand libertarians were pro-choice
I don't know I mean I don't know what
you know what they may be or not be
Justice Thomas has still never expressed
an opinion about abortion or choice he
has voted to overturn Roe and he's been
on the losing side of those cases well I
think that that does speak to his views
but yeah
a hundred years from now what is he
going how will historians remember
Thomas that's been a challenge for a lot
of us that have followed him in his last
- thirteen years that's a very good
question I don't know the answer to it
somebody that I quoted in the book who
was close to him said that Justice
Thomas believes that the only respect
he'll get is after he's dead
and that it will not happen in his
lifetime
you know justices have the advantage of
longevity there's no getting them out
unless they choose to leave or pass on
and justice thomas has been on the court
now 13 years if his health is good he'll
be on another 25 or 30 which today would
make him the longest serving justice in
American history and when you're talking
about three decades or more that is time
to build a legacy so he will have one
I'm sure at the end but what it will be
I don't besides the grandnephew that
he's really close to and he's trying to
to help out does the judge do anything
outreach to the community or to the
church he to the school he went to or as
he hoped outs of a nanny I think you
touched on it once in your in your
report one of the things that he does
that he doesn't really advertise or
publicize is that he does a lot of
mentoring work with school children and
he's been doing it ever since he'd been
has been up at the court he every month
or two he'll have groups of school
children come in they're mostly from the
Washington and Virginia area most of
them are poor children most of them are
black he reserves a conference room at
the court he spends two and three hours
with them and over the years he's
developed one-on-one relationships with
dozen
kids and I quote some of them in the
book one of them that I found was a
young man from Virginia who very very
bright very gifted athlete came from a
broken home and Clarence Thomas arranged
financing for this boy to go to private
school for the next six years so his
approach to helping people is he wants
to do it one-on-one and he wants to see
and and touch and and and actually feel
like he's making a difference rather
than doing it more indirectly
I just can you hear me my cousin's
husband is a doctor in Savannah and it
was very interesting at the time of the
hearings are right after he was telling
me that Justice Thomas mother after
working all day I think in a nursing
home or something like that that she
would push patients to their operations
and she and he said that she'd always
say you must go up to Washington and
meet my son he's a judge up in
Washington and I'm so proud of him but
anyway tonight I just like to say thank
you for telling me a lot of the details
I knew that I'm a teacher and a
librarian and I know that kids that have
mothers that are alone and working
sometimes needs some help and so I was
thought that perhaps the defining factor
in his life was the fact that his
grandfather took a Clarence and his
brother to live with him I didn't know
about the strict discipline but I've
come to say that you can almost lighten
up you know and it sometimes seems harsh
but we have too many kids today that
have it too easy and don't really you
know learn how to work like those kids
did but I just want to thank you for
that and then one of the things that I
wanted to say was I watched the hearings
I was just riveted and I was very torn
because I grew up in Atlanta when it was
segregated I went to segregated schools
they integrated two years after I went
to college my mother is Canadian and she
was for the civil rights bill she also
went to Martin Luther King's funeral
there weren't too many white people but
my mother was there but anyway I was in
college in Chicago I would have been
there with her but the thing that I
thought was the biggest tragedy of the
whole thing was to see the way that a
conservative blacks are so alienated and
so I not a alienated and isolated and it
really makes me sad because I've heard
them accused of not being black and not
being brothers and I just think it's a
good thing that he was alone or it could
or he couldn't have done what he did but
I do think it is very very sad when
conservative blacks are
alienated and really isolated I think
it's it's a tragedy in our country thank
you thank you for that I mean Clarence
Thomas does not view himself as a leader
of any kind of movement but there's no
question that his conservatism and his
visibility as a black conservative made
it easier for people who came behind him
you you do an excellent job I think of
pointing out the personal conflict that
Justice Thomas has always felt to prove
himself but I've always been curious why
and how and I'd like to know if your
research allowed you to get a better
understanding of how that personal
battle impacts so much the much broader
public policy issues are involved in
affirmative action as a a justice as a
lawyer certainly he has studied those
policy issues you know deeply and yet
and it seems he can't get past the
personal demons or conflicts that he
feels over his personal battles to prove
himself Clarence Thomas also has a lot
of legal and a lot of constitutional
arguments for why he is opposed to
affirmative action he does not believe
that the Constitution allows us to
classify people by race he's very very
opposed to classifying people by race
and I think that that came out of his
experience in Savannah under segregation
which is what that system was about
you know it becomes I think very
difficult to separate the personal views
about something the legal views the
constitutional views you know I I am not
a I'm not someone who covers the Supreme
Court on a regular basis but my gut
feeling is that it is the personal views
that come first and then the then they
wrap legal views around that that that
taken that direction
Kent Thomas is so often written off as a
is an idealogue but I don't think we
hear much about him as a legal thinker
as a mind and I'm wondering what
conclusions you reached about the
quality of his mind as a lawyer both at
the EEOC and on the court and what are
what's being said about that in academic
journals and law journals at this point
Clarence Thomas has a very analytical
mind and a very mind that works very
literally linear linearly when he goes
about figuring out how he's going to
come down on a case his the first thing
that he wants to do is go back to the
very beginning and look at that line of
the Court's jurisprudence and figure out
where it went where it turned and if it
turned for the wrong reasons and he is
not afraid to go back often many years
of Supreme Court precedent and say this
particular precedent is wrong we should
throw it out and start again that is not
a widely accepted position four justices
and four judges Justice Scalia told me
when I interviewed him that Justice
Thomas doesn't believe in the doctrine
of precedent or let the decision stand
I think Justice Scalia said he would
throw out a line of our precedent and I
wouldn't do that so you know he's often
described as being sort of the boldest
of the Conservatives but you know he is
he has his own views and he is often
isolated on the court you see lots of
cases where the Supreme Court will come
down eight to one and Clarence Thomas is
the one thank you for your great talk in
for the great article in the Sunday
paper which I have with me and before I
get into my question but I had to say in
listening and reading the article before
I came and I can't wait to read the book
I felt surprisingly um how much in
common I have with him and I have to say
I was just in another context of
somebody asked me about two different
religions we were discussing and talking
about differences and similarities and
she said something and I said you know
that's what the Pope has written he has
been asked well what about all these
different religions all these
differences and he said I'm always
struck by the similarities not the
differences but the similarities so
thank you for for all these details
about him that I'm resonating with me
but my question is I am an art historian
my background and pictures are so
important to me and these pictures are
marvelous but there are no pictures in
the book now whose decision what did
your publisher decide not to put the
pictures er there are pictures of their
art I just did all right
end up all right thank you and when you
said there were surprises I'm assuming
there were good surprises for him and
you said they were surprises about his
backing that he didn't know yes one of
the
things I felt it was important to do for
a black American Supreme Court justice
like thurid's Thomas was to go back as
far as I could with his family and to
know and understand their journey in
this country and I spent a lot of time
researching Clarence Thomas's slave
ancestry he is from Georgia all of his
family is from Georgia every single line
of his family runs through slavery and
there is a chapter of the book that
deals with one of his slave ancestors a
man by the name of Sandy Wilson I
encourage you to read that chapter of
the book I didn't know what I would be
able to find about Clarence Thomas's
ancestors as you know we didn't do a
very good job of keeping records about
black Americans before nineteen 1870 but
I was able to find out a great deal
about this man and he had a remarkable
life journey he was born into slavery in
1812 he won his freedom when General
Sherman marched to the sea in Savannah
seven years after gaining his freedom he
blocked 40 acres of land with his own
money and he lived the left or the rest
of his life as a free man and that is a
powerful powerful story and there were
other details about Myers Anderson and
his journey through Jim Crow in the
1920s and 30s 40s that I also think were
meaningful to justice Thomas
I was curious as to what you learned
about him that you admire and want the
way that he is and in his life and in
the world that you admired and thought
that you'd want to be more that way
yourself perhaps and as I was standing
here I said thought I wondered what you
thought of him from the beginning
and then what you came to know of him
after he got to the end of the process
yeah you know the interesting thing
about it is that I didn't really know a
whole lot about Clarence Thomas when I
started researching his life I was a
Washington correspondent for the Atlanta
Constitution and I knew that he was from
Georgia and I knew that he was one of
the nine most powerful judges in the
country and that was reason enough that
I thought that my newspaper oughta cut
me loose to write some stories about him
so I didn't you know I didn't have a lot
of preconceived notions I did read a lot
as I got going and you know most of what
had been written about Justice Thomas
after his confirmation is that he was
this very angry and bitter man still
licking his wounds and there were lots
of stories about how he didn't ask
questions and always voted with his
colleague Justice Scalia which I thought
seemed to be insinuating or suggesting
that he wasn't that bright so yeah I
didn't really know much about him and
but the more that I you know the more
that I knew about him the more than I
thought gee this is a fascinating man
with a very very interesting story I
mean the things that I respect about
Clarence Thomas are his discipline his
work ethic
I had his tenacity
honey thank you very much I'm I grew up
in Arkansas during a Little Rock Central
time all the father's so at the risk of
sounding controversial let me tell you I
am NOT an admirer of Clarence Thomas at
all I am very curious with this being
the 50th year of brown whether you had
discussion with him about his legacy
particularly compare it with that of
Thurgood Marshall I mean as we look back
50 years ago we can see a huge impact
Thurgood Marshall had on society it's
not perfect but there's been huge
progress I'm curious if you ever talked
to Clarence Thomas about that what is
that about it I I didn't ask him
specifically about brown but Clarence
Thomas is not Thurgood Marshall he is a
very very different man he has a very
very different views I do think it's
been it's been difficult for him because
that is the standard to which he is held
and that's a very very high standard to
equal particularly when you know in his
case his politics and his ideas are
different the major difference that I
see between Thurgood Marshall and
Clarence Thomas is that Marshall really
thought that the only way the United
States could overcome its legacy of
discrimination was to put race into the
law and support things like affirmative
action
Thomas's view is the only way that we
become sort of one country is to take
race out of the law and that's it's a
very different that's a different very
different position
at that did you come to any personal
conclusion about whether he or she was
telling the truth in the in the
proceedings
I interviewed about 300 people for this
book and I would guess that about 200 of
them offered their take on that episode
and what they believed or didn't believe
many of these people worked very closely
with Clarence Thomas at the EEOC and at
the Department of Education not one of
them believed that he was capable of
saying the things that he said to Anita
Hill in the way and in the times and the
places that she alleged that he said
them which was as a way to you know
really bully had intimidate and harass
her you can say a lot of things about
Clarence Thomas but he's not a bully
never has been he's also a very cautious
man and he's not reckless by Nature
having said that I think it's possible
that he did say some of those things
Clarence Thomas I mean he was 31 32
years old he came of age when
pornography was just hitting the
mainstream and it didn't have the stigma
attached to it that it does now he was
known by his friends to be very coarse
and irreverent in private social
settings
so I think it's possible that he may
have said some of those things but I
think it's unlikely that he said them in
the times and the places and in the way
that I need a he'll allege that he did
this is solder related to that you said
that you'd welcome questions about his
personal association with Anita Hill and
that solar that's it wide open was it
sexual was it professional was it just
casual friendship it seemed to me at the
time that those opposing him wanted to
believe it make it be a success of
sexual relationship and I think that
does a great deal of disservice to the
man personally unless you got actual
proof that he actually was guilty of
sexual harassment and so forth which
from what I could gather there's been no
real proof for it it's all been kind of
a political thing I appreciate your
comment yeah